the moment babies are born their minds
are dominated by a powerful implicit
question what do I need to do in order
to be loved
we have to remember that babies are
entirely at the mercy of the prevailing
environment and therefore knowing what
exactly the people in this environment
want from them in exchange for keeping
them alive is Central to their very
survival
furthermore how the question is answered
will shape their entire personalities
and sense of adult priorities who we are
is predominantly the result of what we
needed to do to capture and sustain the
interest of the people who put us on the
Earth
there are broadly three answers to the
baby's question let's go through them in
turn
firstly nothing very much
a certain sort of parent immediately
makes it clear the baby doesn't need to
do anything to deserve to exist they are
allowed to be they don't need to do
their own needs come first who they are
and what they want is the priority in
those early fragile months and years
from such a base a child can grow up
liking themselves and adjusting to the
needs of others without too great a loss
of creativity or individuality they
don't have to do anything extraordinary
to feel that they are okay and if they
happen to do it anyway it will simply be
out of a sense of inherent curiosity and
appetite
this is needless to say the love we
should all want and have had
then comes another kind of answer
to earn love you must succeed
for a certain kind of parent the baby's
existence is premised on an enormous
requirement the child has to help the
parent to feel much better about
themselves they have to help them to
paper over their inadequacies
compromises and insecurities
for example to ward off any risk that
the parent might be thought stupid the
child has to demonstrate extreme
intelligence to compensate for the
parents lack of a stellar career the
child has to shine globally to appease
the parents fear of ugliness the child
has to be blatantly pretty to ward off
fears of dullness and the pull of
depression the child needs to be a
cheerful comic
child is a compensatory object at the
behest of the parents disguised
vulnerabilities they are not allowed to
be shy hesitant confused quiet or
unimpressive to strangers for all this
would devastate and Madden an already
precariously balanced parent
from such an upbringing the child will
constantly be left wondering what they
can do next to generate Applause in a
claim they will exhaust themselves in
the pursuit of a love that should have
been theirs from the first
then there is a third kind of answer to
the baby's question to earn love
you must fail
some children have to succeed in order
to be loved some even more Darkly are
commanded to fail
there are parents who will only tolerate
children who don't threaten their place
in the world they are not allowed to be
any happier more beautiful or more
successful and if they come anywhere
close to being so a vengeful aggression
will make itself felt
child understands well enough the rule
they have been placed under they can be
expected to grow up with Advanced
Tendencies to self-sabotage and
underperformance
they promised to be beautiful they'll be
sure not to take any pleasure in their
physical appearance if they're on track
to do well at school they'll ensure that
they manage always to fail the final
exam if they end up with a good career
they'll do their utmost to show their
rivalrous parent that it isn't any fun
really to be them perhaps by developing
a psychological disorder that guarantees
a demonstrable misery
sometimes even more perplexingly more
than one message emanates from a single
parent the parent swings between wanting
a child to shore them up and fearing
that they are threatening them the child
will be under pressure both to succeed
and to fail there will be nowhere for
the benighted soul to turn
what we can be sure is that anything
other than the first message will leave
us with a highly complex and unfortunate
Legacy we need to be extremely
compassionate towards ourselves and the
babies we once were who heard such a
puzzling and devastating answer to that
powerless
urgent first question what do I need to
do to be allowed to live